et par merveilles du monde que ce
bonheur ils deviennent le choco buzzer
par les pouvoirs du calacs ancestrale
[Musique]
chéri il est 20 heures
oui et c'est quelque chose de très
important à vous dire tune allocution
que je voulais faire depuis longtemps
sachez le
il y a eu au cours de ces dernières
semaines des attaques au chocolat ces
attaques ont parfois sales il est
chroniqueur dans leur corps dans leur
tête et dans leur chair et le public et
le public également
le public aime la dar k o et on sera
toujours partisan de la barca mais après
ce 1er mai où j'ai beaucoup réfléchi
bien marcher marcher marcher des heures
et des heures pour arriver à cette
conclusion le chocolat gate ne va pas
s'arrêter
je me suis fait mal non non non non pas
comme ça non le chocolat gate ne
s'arrêtera pas le chocolat gates va à
partir de maintenant
devenir encore plus grand encore plus
fort encore plus lourd encore plus
majestueux encore plus exceptionnel à
votre image à votre image le chocolat
gates va devenir quoi mondial et je
m'adresse aujourd'hui à tous les chefs
d'état qui nous regardent les poutines
l'e-tron les marrons si les deux chefs
d'état que je connais et berkane
ce qui nous regarde et attend sachez que
j'ai ici le choco bonne peur et dans un
hosto je déclencherai sochaux cow-boy
buzz mais si je le mettrais en marche
pour la suite des événements nacre
énorme et dans un instant vous saurez
quelle va être la fonction de ce show
qu'au bonheur et tous ceux qui nous
regardent que vous soyez chez vous que
vous soyez prêts que vous soyez loin que
vous soyez en trottinette en overboard
[Rires]
les hacher que super choco vous regarde
oui rigolez pas dans la tronche de
barthez fléchir et vous vous le dit
l'harmonie le chocolate va se
délocaliser à a
et vous aussi chez vous avez vous serez
partisans le chocolate
sachez le maintenant à partir de
maintenant le chocolat gates va se
délocaliser
car vous aussi vous pourrez
faire partie du chocolat gates et de la
confrérie du chocolat sachez en tout cas
que ce chocolat c'est du chocolat varié
avec de l'eau mettez beaucoup d'eau et
un petit peu de chocolat variés il ya
bien on fait une mixture malade ça on
est rassuré alors favorisée pour rien au
bout le sens où il supprime c'est pourri
non non non ne riez pas de ces pourris
les chéris je vais dans l'acte iv le
chocobo heures au caire que j'ai menées
par les pouvoirs du kinder bueno
[Rires]
par toutatis partout x lakers et par
merveilles du monde que ce buzzer vie
devienne le chocobo heures par les
pouvoirs du calacs ancestrale choco
buzzer
c'est fait sachez qu'à partir de
maintenant
bossi garrett à productrice julie
raynaud me dise comment fait comment on
fait pour s'inscrire parce que vous
aussi vous allez pouvoir vous allez
pouvoir choco buzz et quelques à chaque
jour chaque jour il ya une adresse mail
et 7jours ja purée sur ce buzzer et
quelqu'un en france se fera chocobo's y
a quelqu'un quelqu'un qu'a dit quelque
chose
ça a été un voilà donc à partir de
maintenant je chocobo's ray tous les
jours ça a annoncé l'ini c'est choco
bost et pmp at gmail.com vous envoyez un
mail vous expliquez nous expliquer votre
cas et on chocobo sera quelqu'un est ce
que vous êtes chauds pour le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]